Bill Gates is the co-founder of
Microsoft who changed the world by
revolutionising the way that we use
computers
he went from dropping out of Harvard in
order to become an entrepreneur to
becoming one of the richest men on the
planet with a net worth of a hundred and
five billion dollars and one of the
biggest philanthropists as well need
motivation what's your top 10 with
believe nation
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best bill gates
and my take on his top ten rules of
success enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one love what you do most people over
the last 200 years or so whoever they
the wealthiest person in the world was
didn't usually work that hard when they
got to be sixty or so they kind of took
life easy you seem to be working pretty
hard what motivates you to still work so
hard well I love my work the work of the
foundation is super interesting I get to
meet with the scientists I get to go out
in the field I do think your habits are
sort of set in your 20s and 30s and by
my standards of the twenties well you
know I didn't believe in weekends back
then not to mention vacations so I'm you
know fairly lazy compared to myself in
my 20s where I was a true fanatic you
know all I believed in was working on
software night and day and and for my
20s that was perfect I didn't have a
wife or family at all and my role was
very hand hands-on role rule number two
fight for acceptance in the early days
you know you were just a college dropout
you were very young looking did you get
taken seriously by business men who are
much older for some people that youth
and geekiness was like eh should we
trust them you know that's so weird
we've never seen something like that
before so yes we had to fight for
acceptance I couldn't rent cars so I had
to take cabs around because I was too
young and you know probably some people
were a little tough but then as we got a
little bit of success people were
fascinated by this deep belief we had in
in software rule number three avoid the
negative outlook we think that progress
can actually accelerate the laughs did
last 15 years have been wonderful but
the next 15 we can do more
and some people worry that when you you
talk about progress that it'll reduce
people's commitment to make things
better they think when you talk about
progress that it shows you're naive and
that maybe you don't realize all those
things that are left to be done and how
horrific they are and you know so
sometimes that purely that negative side
of the story gets told but you lose
something very important if you only
look at it that way you lose the
optimism about what's possible and you
lose the information where you look at
the places that have done better than
others and you understand what is it
about delivery innovation partnerships
caring what has come together for the
very best progress and then spread that
to the other places that's what will
help us drive at full speed rule number
four take calculated risks urgency that
I felt that if we didn't get Microsoft
going right away that somebody would do
a great job building a software company
we won't have a chance that probably
ended up not being true that I could
have waited two or three years and the
opportunity to do Microsoft still would
be there but anyway I felt a sense of
urgency and you know it's not like you
know I still get to take courses and
learn things today you know things like
the learning company and there's all
sorts of great books so it's not like
I've missed some part of my education
but you dropped out your father and
mother said are you sure you know what
you want to do it one of your children
dropped out of college to start a
company what would you say well I'd have
to say yes but the dropping out is not
an irrevocable decision you know if you
try and start a company it doesn't go
well they always let you go back and so
if you don't have you know kids that you
need to support you know it's a very
low-risk thing particularly in the
culture of the United States we're
trying to start something and and
failing is not a black mark for the rest
of your life
also if you want to have more confidence
and learn from billionaires check out my
254 series where every day for the next
254 days I'll send you an awesome
unlisted video to your email to help you
shift your confidence forward
the links are joined for free are in the
description below you really have to
believe the Internet's going to be
mainstream a lot of people are gonna get
out there and use it when you have the
level of success that we've had when you
have a business that's important as this
with this many competitors you're going
to have people saying some nasty things
if you ask people across the United
States is the future going to be better
than the past most say no rule number
five swing for the fences I feel like
you always seem to swing for the fences
in general it's just sort of any way of
framing it but I have to ask if you are
swinging for the fences what if you miss
well hopefully you get more than one
swings either had the same problem like
you know multiple malaria vaccine
construct so that you know if you have
two or three the combined chance of
success much higher or that you're
working in multiple areas not just one
area right you know in climate for
example I have a company that's trying
to make a nuclear reactor that would be
very cheap and that would have safeties
so that the public would be very
accepting of it now you know even I
realize that's high risk you know less
than 50% chance all that comes together
and yet if it did and the only reason
I'm involved is it would really help
with climate let us generate electricity
without any greenhouse gases rule number
six do volunteer work knowing that
you're doing all this work but someone
in my position I'm not a philanthropist
I don't necessarily have the means how
does someone like me or someone watching
this help in the best way they can well
I wish more people could actually get to
these countries you know join the Peace
Corps spend time even just spending a
few weeks there and see how great the
needs are and see the progress a lot of
you know volunteer work
and the United States builds that sense
of okay we care about other humans even
you know beyond our own family group
even people have very different
experiences so you know at a young age a
little bit of giving money away you know
to form that habit and picking which
things you really want to give to
including lots of things here in the US
and getting involved with volunteer time
those are the people who I think will
help kind of bring the world together
and you know avoid just this divisive
Ness that is is my greatest concern rule
number seven use technology for your
advantage historically the newspapers or
the the media were very responsible
about not letting untruths about vaccine
safety get out there now it's you know
the you don't want to get rid of the
good thing which is that anybody can
publish that barriers to entry the
diversity of voices is so phenomenal
compared to traditional publishing right
I feel like and you have a bit of
YouTube presence so you're able to share
information about things through social
media it's kind of a social media age so
I feel like that ideally helps your
cause more than a hurts it yeah my
audience probably isn't deep with the
vaccine doubters yeah you know I in a
creative way
trying to get positive messages to be
interesting and we have work to do on
that you know I would have thought using
experts sometimes that acknowledge that
the all the internet would just make it
so much easier to learn about things and
yet in some ways you know people aren't
seeking out complex information
particularly that it disagrees with some
preconceived notion that they have so
you know how can social media get out
there and be a little bit of a force for
education particularly on climate where
yeah without a consensus
we won't do the hard things that will
save things for the next generation rule
number eight don't focus on one product
when you were starting Microsoft there
were a lot of other software companies
and you were not number one at the
beginning I think there were mothers who
were a little bit further ahead what was
it that enabled you to beat everybody
else up in the software business was it
Bill Gates was it something else what
was the unique factor that made you the
most successful yeah we were actually
the first and but there were companies
and they were all kind of single product
companies who got ahead of us
in terms of sales you know by about 1991
we did become the largest of all of them
we were an engineering company we were
about how you hire smart people and how
you use tools to develop software
broadly we were global and we weren't
about a single product so like for
example WordPerfect was a word processor
somebody might remember they did so well
with that product that their gross sales
rivaled ours when we were doing a broad
set of products as soon as graphics
interface caught on which was Windows
that became mainstream in 1995 we became
far larger than the other software
companies now subsequently you know
Google Apple Amazon had become you know
also extremely successful but in the 90s
we were the strongest okay by far rule
number nine focus on big numbers the
idea that you could get people to to
decide to support this for inane thing
which is a big deal for our foundation
from a numeric point of view we're still
pushing that a little bit but honestly
the story of the one child you know if
you say to an audience here's the
picture of the child shall we save this
child they're more engaged than if you
said hey let's save a million children
you know so there's definitely
sort of you know ten to the six problem
here somewhere that humans are not wired
to be to do that on a numeric basis and
so you know that's why we have people
like Bono and and many others who come
from a more storytelling world and then
they let me throw a few charts and
numbers in just because I think that
that should should be there once your
heart tells you what direction to go in
to prove that this is a very affordable
not you know not a big deal well-managed
path to to be on and we'll number ten
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is build your relationships and
Microsoft my early partner was Paul
Allen and then Steve Ballmer was my
partner now Melinda's you know even a
totally equal partner and all the
foundation work we're doing so she she
and I run it together it was so
fascinating I mean the relationships we
were building learning all this new
stuff to have somebody to brainstorm
with about it you know made it a lot
more fun you know things like writing
letters together giving speeches
together we had to learn how to bring
out the best of the both of us and in
doing those things but yeah it was
always you know clear we wanted to do it
together now I've got a really special
bonus clip that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that if you're still
here watching I want to celebrate you if
you commit to taking an action after
watching this video we don't just watch
videos we do something about it
give me a hash tag believe down the
comments as well we had been working day
and night these were pretty maniacal
days in terms of work was everything
even you know I didn't believe in
weekends or vacations the team pretty
broadly had worked super super hard the
marketing people had figured out how to
take this phenomena and you know get
create a lot of excitement around it
if you want more top ten videos they're
not on this channel anymore I have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and I'll see you
there